[Müzik]
burada Genelde insanlar çıkınca çok
duygusal şeyler konuşacakmış gibi oluyor
veya böyle insan duygusal bir moda
giriyor
epeyle karanlık
her şey
lisedeyken İzmit'te yabancı bir kıza
Türkçe bir şarkıyı çevirmeye çalışırken
başladı
Yağmurun Sesine Bak aşk
Yağmurun sesine bak Allah Allah
halk kulübe
nasıl bakabilir ki
İşte o an Türkçe ile ilgili daha önce
sorgulamadığım her şey sağanak bir
yağmur gibi başımdan aşağı akmaya
başladı Tıpkı Newton'ın bir elmanın
düşüşüyle şiir gibi oldu değil mi
Okey tıpkı'nın bir elmanın dışişiyle
Yerçekimi keşfetmesi gibi her şeyi
sorguladım her şeyi Biz bugüne kadar ben
nasıl bir Türkçe konuşuyordum Acaba
nasıl bir iletişim modelin vardı
Yağmurun Sesine bakıyordum Halbuki
yağmurunun sesini duymak gerekiyordu
bu ne oluyordu acaba düşündüm Ad
aktarması vardı ya Eylem aktarması gibi
bir şey sonra aklıma geldi bir sürü şey
tabağını bitir Annemin söyledikleri
kapıyı çalmak
bilirsiniz Mesela annem çok şey derdi
evladım ayağını giy
Allah Allah Yani Ad aktarması değil bu
daha çok böyle duble Ad aktarması Ad
aktarması gibiydi
bir sürü şey düşündüm Türkler nasıldı
acaba biz nasıl iletişim kuruyorduk camı
siliyorduk ayna gibi oluyordu aynayı
siliyoruz cam gibi oluyor
Arkadaşlar biz de karşıdan karşıya
geçmek diye bir şey var
insan karşıdan karşıya nasıl geçebilirdi
böyle bir iletişim modeli Acaba bir
Kader miydi yoksa tercih mi yani Ben
size söyleyeyim Bu iletişim modeli bize
atalarımızdan kalan bir miras ama
atalarımızın tercihiydi Türkçe
dünyanın en gelişmiş proje dili Yani
aslında Tabii ki Bütün diller doğaldır
bütün dillerin defaultusunda fabrika
ayarları Allah vergisi zaten bir
yaklaşım modeli vardır ama Türkçe
insanın fabrika ayarlarından yani doğal
yaklaşımından en çok ileri gitmiş en
gelişmiş değildir ve bunu atalarımızın
aldığı kararlara borçluyuz Ben Taner
Çağla 2005 yılında girdiğim Doğa
adliyesi'nden 2005 yılında birincilikle
girdiğim Doğu Akdeniz Üniversitesi'nden
2009 yılında sonunculukla mezun oldum
sonucu olmamın bir sebebi vardı kafayı
buna takmıştım Türkçe'ye biz neden böyle
konuşuyoruz bakın
Bu nedir
siz söyleyin nereye taktım
koluma dünyada saati koluna takan tek
millet Türk milleti bütün dünya saati
bileğine takarken Bizler kolumuza
takıyoruz
bütün dünya bebek doğururken biz çocuk
doğuruyoruz Bütün dünya bir şeyin
ağırlığını sorarken bakın ağırlığını
Bizler kilosunu soruyoruz
düşündüm ve
Üniversite hayatın boyunca aslında
başarısız olmamın yani üniversiteyi
sonuncu bitirmemin bir sebebi vardı Bir
hayalim vardı Her şeyi çeviren bir robot
yazılım yapmak istiyordum yani bakın
Burası birazcık daha TED konuşmasına
daha uygun Çünkü Benimki ders gibi bir
şeyler daha önce bunu konuşurken Ne
konuşacağız ne yapacağız diye hep ekibe
şunu söyledim ben bir şey öğretmeden
duramam bir şey öğretmek zorundayım Bu
sahneden indiğimde Hayalim Her şeyi
çeviren Bir yazılım yapmaktı
üniversitedeki hocalarım asla böyle bir
şey yapamazsın diyorlardı Elbette bir
bildikleri vardı ama ben kafayı buna
takmıştım üniversiteden mezun oldum ve
bir yazılımcı bir yatırımcı bulmak için
İstanbul'a geldim
bu süreçte dil okullarında çalışıyordum
böyle beni yabancı Hoca kontenjanından
konuşma odaklı sınıflara tayin
ediyorlardı oralarda ciddi bir problemle
karşılaştım insanlar anlıyorlardı ama
konuşamıyorlardı aranızda eminim anlayıp
konuşamayan vardır şimdi bakalım ben
Bu yazılım projesinde yani her şeyi
çeviren bir robot yapmaya çalışırken
suratıma tokat gibi çarpan bir gerçekle
karşılaştım bütün dünya ama İngilizce
olsun buradaki hani örneğimiz
İngilizce'de 1 milyon kelime varken
insanların görünce bir şey anladığı
Türkçede yüz bin civarında kelime var
bizim görüp Aa ben bunu biliyorum
dediğimiz şimdi bu öyle büyük bir gerçek
ve öyle büyük bir sorundu ki bu aslında
bütün öğrencilerin ve sizin de Neden
özellikle anlayıp konuşamadığınızın da
göstergesiydi bakın
en çok duyduğumuz sizin de en çok
söylediğiniz Kesinlikle Türkiye'de her
zaman şahit olduğumuz bir şikayet
anlıyorum ama konuşamıyorum sonra bunu
araştırmaya başladım İnsan neden anla
arama konuşamaz Siz de aklınızdan
geçirin sorgulayın anlattığım her şeyi
ben zaten ne hissettiğinizi ne
düşündüğünüzü göreceğim bakın Türkçenin
bir felsefesi var bu iş her şeyden önce
bir felsefe meselesi Çünkü değil 4
aşamada öğrenilir felsefe matematik yani
mantığı ezber ve refleks yani
konuşacaksın Türkçe der ki bir olacağız
iri olacağız diri olacağız ve bunun için
şöyle bir dil tasarlamıştır
gelemeyebilirdik Bakın gelemeyebilirdik
size göre hemen hap gibi bir kelime
Çünkü biz resim resim konuşuruz hayatta
sen bundan bir şey anlıyorsun gördüğün
zaman şu an senin için çok basit bir
cümle 3 yaşındaki bir çocuğa bile
gelemeyebilirdik de diyebilirsin ve
düşünmezsin ne kadar Aslında kompleks
bir yapı olduğunu Halbuki içinde bakın
neler var
Tam 7 tane mesaj var gelmek olayın
kendisi e kapasite bakın kapasite mema o
gelme olayı gelme kapasitesinin
yetersizliği edebilmek gelme
kapasitesinin
yetersizliğinin gerçekleşmeme ihtimali
İyi gelme kapasitesinin yetersizliğinin
gerçekleşmeme ihtimalinin gelecekte
olması idi gelme kapasitesinin
yetersizliğinin gerçekleşmeme
ihtimalinin geçmişteki bir gelecekte
olması ve
Şimdi sen bunların hepsini bir çırpıda
ağzından söylüyorsun ve İngilizcenin
felsefesine baktığımız zaman böl parçala
Yönet kardeşim ne uzatıyorsun Niye o
kadar beni yoruyorsun ve neden bu kadar
bir kaos'un içinde beni sıkıştırıyorsun
atalarımızın illaki bir bildiği vardı
Onlar Çünkü şunu düşünüyorlardı Belki de
at üstünde idi belki Kılıç sallıyordu ok
atıyordu ve belki zaman sorunu vardı ve
zamanı çok iyi yönetmesi gerekiyordu ama
İngiliz dedi ki bununla bu şekilde
uğraşmak yerine Daha doğrusu Biz tersini
söyledik Ama bu
nightable yani bizim 7 mesajı tek bir
parçada söylerken biz onlar milleti
mesajı üzerine artı bir koyarak 8 kelime
ile söylemeyi tercih etti Sen birinci
olarak bu yüzden bence anlıyorsun Çünkü
sana bütün mesajlar net geliyor ama
konuşamıyorsun Çünkü senden çıkan
mesajlar net değil
sonraki kıyaslamaya başladım Türkçe
nasıl bir değil İngilizce nasıl bir dil
bakın Türkçe
Türkçede iletişim abddana anlatır
gibidir İngilizce iletişim aptana
anlatır gibidir neden
örneğe bak diyor ki Diyoruz ki biz
başıma taş düştü Şimdi burada bundan bir
şey anlayabilmen için senin zeka
kullanman gerekir Türkçe dünyada en
fazla zeka kullanılması gereken değil
burada bir şey diyorsan ama bir şey de
demiyorsun başıma bir taş düştü
demiyorsun tıpkı'nın başına bir elma
düşmesi gibi elma düştü deseydik de
anlayacaktık ama başıma taş düştü yerine
başıma taş yağdı deseydim Az önce birle
doldurduğun boşluğu şimdi nerelerle
dolduracaktım başıma taş yağdı Neden
Çünkü Türkçe diyor ki yağmak var diyorum
ki nedenler yazmadın
zaten yağmak çoğul bir eylemse bir daha
ilerler Demeye ne gerek var
Başımıza taş yağdı diyorum işte orada
film kopuyor Çünkü o zaman
söylemediğimiz iki şey var
başlarımıza taşlar yağdı
ve sen İngilizce konuşurken bunlara
dikkat edip bunları söylemek zorundasın
Ama tabii Bizim günümüz ne ile geçiyor
öğrenci gelip hep şey diyor Hocam bunu
söylemesek olurum bakın Bütün Kariyerim
şunu duymakla geçti Hocam bunu
söylemesem olur mu hocam bu da
söylemesem olur mu yani diyor ki hocam
the var ya demesek olur mu Çünkü biz
demiyoruz ya bize soruyla Yanlış kişiye
soruyorsun işte bunu demesek olur mu
diyen bizim atalarımızmış Yıllar yıllar
önce onlar zaten oturmuş düşünmüş demiş
ki ya bizim bir sürü derdimiz var kim
uğraşacak dığının Türkçesini söylemekle
bilin işte bir demekle ve atmış devam
ettim kıyaslamaya dedim ki Türkçe nasıl
bir değil bakın Türkçe karşı taraf kör
değilmiş gibi konuşulurken İngilizce
karşı taraf körmüş gibi konuşulur ben
gelirim sana derim ki bana sandalye
getir
gerçekten de
bir demediğim halde bir sandalye
getirirsin ama şöyle deseydim sana bak
bir demedim
bize sandalye getir deseydim yanımda bir
arkadaşımla Bunun iki sandalye mesajı
olduğunu yine ben söylemeden
anlayacaktım O yüzden İngilizce ne diyor
bana sandalye getir deyince bir demek
zorunda
çok olduğunu söylemek zorunda
Az önce bize sandalye dediğimde iki
sandalye getirirken bize taksi dediğimde
yine dönüp bir sandalye getiriyor çünkü
biliyor ki Taksi 4 kişiliktir Siz kol
kola iki kişi olduğunuza göre bir
sandalyeye bir taksiye sığarsınız
Türkçe bakın iletişim dediğimiz şey
Dünyanın %97'si Beynin sol tarafında
çalışırken diller dünya dillerinin yüzde
üçü ve Türkçe tepede olmak üzere Beynin
sağ tarafında çalışıyor ve genel olarak
Aslında manuel count'ın bir lafı var
diyor ki bütün değil yani dil dediğin
şey düşüncenin imgelenmesidir Ben de
şunu söylüyorum arkadaş İngilizce
konuşmak istiyorsan Hatta İtalyanca
Rusça Almanca herhangi bir dili konuşmak
istiyorsan şu an aklına gelen tek bir
şey bilmen lazım zihninde ne varsa
zikrinde o olsun Oysa Türkçe bir
iletişim kurarken bir cümle kurarken
zihnindekine önce bir filtreden bir zeka
filtresinden geçiriyor ve ondan sonra
dile getiriyor bakın cümleye bak diyorum
ki bak şapkalı asker bak şapkalı asker
Burada iki tane kelime var
ingilizce'sine bakıyorum
look ve One ve the Cape a
8 kelime Yani senin çocuğun senin
çocuğun 02 yaş arasında şapkalı asker
diyebilirken Onun çocuğu 0-2 yaş
arasında look The One
8 kelime demek zorunda ve İngiliz'in
karısı şöyle diyemiyor kocasına Bey
bizim çocuk daha 2 yaşında ne vardı
demese Evet bugün de ee demesin çocuğum
diyemiyor hepsini demek zorunda Oysa Biz
ne yapmamışız veya Biz Neyi atmışız
Türkçe'de yok muymuş Türkçede de varmış
Bir zamanlar şöyle olduğunu düşün
bir şapkaya sahip bir şapkalı Malum kişi
eşittir bir asker
şimdi Türkçeyi sen böyle konuşuyor
olsaydın belki şu an korkunç geliyor
İngilizce öğrenmek senin için bir
peçeteye yazıp öğrenmek kadar kolay
olacaktı ama sen buradan İngilizceye
gitmiyorsun ki sen İngilizceye şuradan
gidiyorsun şapkalı asker iki kelime
İngilizcesi 8 kelime devam ettim
sonra bazı çıkarımlarda bulundum Tabii
en önemli çıkarımda şu; ne dediğin değil
ne demediğin önemli Türkçede Yani sen
zihnindeki her şeyi attığın için aslında
dediklerinden Çok demediğine bakacaksın
Örneğin Şimdi bunu okusa şurada herkes
içinden okusun
görünen şey iki artı 2 eşittir 4 bu
senin zihninde olan versiyon Gayet
güzeldi 2+2=4 görüyoruz ilgili ama
atalarımızın Aslında yaşı yaptığı
operasyonu düşünelim demiş ki atalarımız
ya
2+2=4 ama biraz kısaltalım zor oluyor 2
artı 2 4'tür Sonra demiş ki biraz daha
kısaltamaz mıyız
2+2 4 sonra
birileri daha gelmiş Demiş ki biraz daha
kısaltabilir miyiz Seni mi kıracağım
demiş ve iki iki dört olmuş yani şöyle
bir İngilizce düşünün my friend Please
görme sebebimiz bu
bakın Oysa İngilizce zihinde başlıyor ve
zihinden sonra hiçbir işlemden geçmeden
hayal ettiği şeyi söylüyor tü Plus
Ya şöyle bir İngilizce laf göremezsin
Ben bazen matematik öğretmeninin çocuğa
ders anlattığını görüyorum Türkçe böyle
yapıyor bak evladım 5 7 12 3 15 15 15 30
İngilizce Düşünsene şöyle anlattığını
look seven five
twenty for twenty for
böyle bir İngilizce olmaz hepsini
söylemek zorunda üşenmeden
şimdi
hepinizin problemi Aslında konuşamıyor
hepinizin derken yani Türkiye'de genel
problemin anlayıp konuşamamak olduğu
düşünülüyor düşünülüyor ya işte onunla
ilgili benim en sevdiğim örneklerden
birisi
Bizim bize göre güzel Türkçe
bağlaçlardan ve kompleks yapılardan
oluşan bir cümle biz buna güzel Türkçe
Yani sen şuna güzel Türkçe diyorsun 3
yaşındaki bir çocuk şu cümleyi kursa her
hafta bir kitap okumak zor olsa bile
bunu başaracağına inanıyorum dese dersin
ki süper cümle İngilizcesi ne yazdım
işte
Bakın bu versiyon Türkçede popüler olan
iken İngilizce'de popüler olan versiyon
şu; her hafta bir kitap okumalısın
Biliyorum bu zor ama İnanıyorum
başarabilirsin bak başarabilirsin tamam
Sen bu yapıyı tam 5 cümleye bölmeyi
başarsan ve şöyle konuşsan You must Read
a book Andrew week basit I know İTS hard
Zaten iki günde bu cümleyi
öğrenebilirsin Hatta burada
salondakilerin %90'nın bu cümleyi bu
şekilde kurabileceğini biliyorum ama bu
da yetmez bunu biraz hızlı söyleyeceksin
you
can
söyleyeceksin işte hangilerde
konuşuyorsan
şimdi sana güzel geldi dedim kurduğum
cümle Of ne biçim konuşuyor dedim
Halbuki iki günde öğrenebilirsin
Ama sen ne yapmaya çalışıyorsun sen hep
diyorsun ki Teyzesi defterdar olan ulan
teyzesi
her hafta bir kitap okumak zor olsa bile
ben bunu başarabileceğim gerçeğine ve
sana bu güzel Türkçe gibi geliyor
arkadaşlar bizim olayımız şu daha az
kelime daha çok iletişim
Türkçenin bütün araştırmalarım
çalışmalarım şunu gösterdi Türkçe'nin
temel felsefesi temel düşüncesi temel
niyeti daha az kelimeyle daha çok
iletişim kurmak üzerine kurulu ve en
sevdiğim örnek belki de
Adam uyuyor işte kadın bir ses duyuyor
diyor ki kocasına bey bey Adam diyor ki
efendim beybe Hayır Bey
bir ses duydum Adam da diyor ki kedidir
İngilizcesini düşünüyorum Kedi dilinin
İngilizcesi Aa bir bakıyorum
Aygaz duduştu Ages
it is
Wow 7 kelime Ulan ben zaten onu
söyleyeceksem uykundan uyanırım o kadar
söyleyeceksen
biz ne yapıyoruz kedidir deyip geçiyoruz
arkadaşlar Aslında mesele tam olarak bu
Ben her şeyi çeviren Bir yazılım yapma
hayaliyle yola çıkmıştım hocalarım
yapamazsın dedi yapamadım ama
bunu yapmaya çalışmak benim en büyük
tutkum bunu yapmaya çalışmaktı ve bu
tutku beni hayal bile edemeyeceğim bir
eğitim sistemi icat etmeye götürdü Yani
aslında ben bir şeyler hayal ederken
hayal bile edemeyeceğim
kendimce bir başarıya ulaştım O yüzden
bugün burada doyduğum yerden geldim
doğduğum yerlere İzmit'e bir İzmitli
olarak beni dinlediğiniz için çok
teşekkür ederim Görüşmek üzere